thanks to raycon for sponsoring this
video get yourself 15 off at the link in
the description
hey guys this is going to be a quick
little update vlog if you're here for
science then there'll be some more of
that
next week in this video i just wanted to
update you on some pretty big
goings-on that have been happening in my
life as you will have already seen
in the video i made on me getting
coronavirus i live in a different house
now this
is different from the house you saw
previously that i lived in with my
ex-girlfriend
uh now live a couple of miles down the
road there are lots of big changes
that have happened but um the biggest
is definitely this
little angel this
is jasmine she is my gorgeous
girl she's a very old girl she's
17. we got her from the shelter
local shelter sadly she's actually been
widowed i guess twice two of her
previous owners
had died apparently unrelated to
ownership of the cat
being old she basically just wants to
sleep and nap and have a bus made out of
her in the evenings which we are
very happy to do
she may be old but as soon as you
introduce her as an enemy
finally a worthy opponent
our battle will be legendary
she looks pissed off the whole time like
she always has that look on her face
where she's like
this [ __ ] again so i don't think it's
just you know resentment for the human
race like it's just
the way her face is quick rundown of
jasmine's favorite places to be
on her bed on the sofa underneath this
lavender bush
and neither is other bush and for some
reason the stairs she really likes being
on the stairs i think when she wants to
be away from people
something that nobody tells you about
cat ownership by the way is that um
your photo roll will now be entirely cat
pictures
like the entire thing is gonna be
multiple pictures of your cat every day
can you explain for the viewers at home
why we got an older cat because she is
an old cat
because simon wanted to watch her die
that is a hundred percent
not true well i've never had a cat
before so i didn't want to
monumentally um mess it up
so instead of committing to a 20-year
commitment i thought a couple of years
well hopefully she'll live for much
longer than that but that would be
a nice trial period trial period
at the moment it looks like she's gonna
outlive us she
kind of has no signs of stopping
whatsoever
it's like wins it it's like an
indefinite trial period now
also because older cats don't get homed
um
we don't want her to die in a home so
nervous oh god that's made me really sad
just thinking about it
as i said earlier this is a new house so
there's a new office here which
you will have seen it in the background
of a bunch of videos uh i can tease that
there is going to be a whole new filming
backdrop coming
in the next couple of weeks um i'll be
doing the behind the scenes of building
the new set over on my patreon if you
fancy
supporting me and getting content a day
early you can do so
there link in the description at the
moment it is a wee bit of a mess
especially a pile of warhammer right
there um but yeah
it's it's nice it's we got the office to
really nice place i've got a good
working station here on this movable
desk finally got these guys mounted up
on the wall as well
it took a couple of years but we got it
in the end and obviously as well as a
new office we've got the new space down
here
which is lovely living space and my
ex-girlfriend
has her working bit here too how do you
feel about being my ex-girlfriend
what i like your ex-girlfriend you're
not my girlfriend anymore
ah i didn't know that he did
actually still calling in my boyfriend
yeah but like you're my fiancee now
because i've been referring to you as my
ex-girlfriend right through the video
okay you seem uh you didn't even notice
too sure i've been blocking your voice
for the last five years
so we're getting married
basically i proposed on our five year
anniversary where it was your idea
that we did a marathon walk into london
uh and halfway through when you are
absolutely lagging and really not
enjoying yourself like
i i was actually able pixelville is the
worst person in the world
at surprises you unpick every
conceivable surprise i've ever done for
you and this is the
one time i pulled it off i did a deep i
had a decoy ring box we had the whole
works
uh i told the whole story over on my
twitch actually if you want the whole
story but yeah i was actually able to
surprise you oh in case people are
wondering i didn't buy this ring
anywhere i
designed it myself i got a jeweler
called phil kidd to build it for me and
he did an amazing job
thank you so much phil pixel girl really
loves the ring you left me hanging when
i proposed
i had to ask like
do you want to say yeah or like that's
because it was just shock
i was i was not expecting it at all so i
was just having some thinking time you
know
yeah when you're thinking ah
yeah that was the internal voice
what i can't run i'm too
that was why i did it then i picked it
up at your most vulnerable moment
yeah we agreed that we couldn't tell
anyone but that was our like motivation
for finishing off this marathon
you were like the terminator i was you
were not stopping for emma that was the
quickest smash and i think i've ever
walked and the first marathon
awards just to answer a question i know
will come up no i'm not filming my
wedding i'm not live-streaming my
wedding
it's we don't even know when it's going
to happen yet because do you want to
give us like millions of pounds then we
will
no we did joke about setting up like a
patreon too yeah it's like a thousand
pounds a month
if you keep that up for a year you can
come to the wedding because you paid for
the wedding
i wanted to sort of do like this is
really what the video is about
uh obviously jasmine is incredibly
important to us i'm more important
yeah uh my favorite thing about her is
how humble she is um
100 loves the cat more than me but it's
so unrequited it's hilarious
no she loves me back she doesn't this
was the main thing this video was going
to be about and
much as this is personal you've been a
part of
me making videos on this channel for as
long as we've been together
so i felt like i wanted to kind of
update
people on the fact that we're gonna get
married
oh god i had like that twinge of like it
feels real
my little family
we have been calling her our daughter
wake up waking up in the morning and be
like we need to feed our daughter
[Music]
sorry i've disturbed you she's do you
want to go back to work
no okay great
pixel girl is currently working on her
master's thesis she's doing a masters in
education at cambridge
and how would you describe your stress
levels
hi
with pixel girls spending so much time
on her thesis i have been doing more of
the housework
and also spending more time just near
her downstairs but so as to not distract
her i've been listening to music and
watching videos
using my everyday e25 earbuds raycon
sent me this pair to review a couple of
months ago and i think i've used them
pretty much every day since i really
like using these earbuds i actually
talked about them already on my twitch
streams but if you missed that most
importantly they sound
great i listen to a lot of videos and
podcasts and they're perfect
for that but i also listen to a lot of
coral and classical music
and i like the fact that these have got
a really good bass response i want that
vm
solo the e25s have six hours of play
time and they fit in a case that can
fully charge them
four times so in the before times i just
had them in my bag whenever i went out
and about on the train or went to the
gym or whatever and they would always be
charged they sound great they connect to
my phone and my laptop super fast
and they mean that i don't distract or
annoy pixel girl with whatever i want to
listen to
best of all though they're about half
the price of other premium earbuds now
raycon sent me these for free
to review but if you'd like to get a
pair yourself then you can do so at
fifteen percent off at byraecon.com
forward slash
simon clark link in the description and
i'd honestly recommend that you do
i'm going to keep using these ones and
would recommend them to
basically anyone who wants some
tangle-free
fuss-free good quality audio thanks to
raycon for sponsoring this video
and for keeping jasmine supplied with
cat treats
[Music]
you